once a month kama presents its own
in-house runway show the company is
known for being fast-paced every four
weeks they present a new small
collection fashion from the German
provinces near Vicksburg Sonya Blanco is
the boss here and she always enjoys
presenting the new collections
of course they're a highlight every
month because they always generate
anticipation and enthusiasm and it's
always a great feeling when you get
everything right in six years kama has
managed to quadruple its sales volume to
160 million euros last year the company
is constantly designing Blazers blouses
and skirts a permanent workshop for the
boss and her designers from all over the
country 110 employees work on the main
premises there are a few men this is
fashion for women by women elegant
outfits with a cool touch to the typical
Kama look is always a bit special we
like to think about how we can emphasize
the feminine silhouette and we place
great value on small loving details we
love offering customers a great
selection in business fashion but we
also have fantastic outfits for when
they meet their friends to go to the
cinema to break the mold a bit they
proudly explain how they've managed a
successful balancing act between high
quality and reasonable prices up to 70%
of the fabrics and collections are
produced in Europe especially Eastern
Europe the rest comes from textile
factories in Southeast Asia where so
much is manufactured for European
fashion labels believing vat of death we
attach great importance to making sure
all our production facilities are
thoroughly inspected and have signed our
code of conduct we have an overriding
structure with plenty of safety barriers
built into it so we feel very good about
our procurement policies that's why
comest still produces in low-wage
countries such as Indonesia saying that
otherwise it would be impossible to keep
up with the competition in the mid-range
price category the brand is now a strong
presence in many of Germany's shopping
districts the company runs more than 90
outlets of its own like this one in
votes book
it's also represented in major clothing
stores in more than 20 countries
worldwide department and fashion stores
are glad to share in its success
fifteen Yub Yub Mia as you see we've
positioned comma in a prime spot of
course that gives it the immediate
desirability because customers go up to
it and have no choice but to take a look
and buy new items unser pop went to here
and Roy answered Lydon as a subsidiary
of the major German fashion label s
Oliver comma is already targeting its
next sales record aiming to top the 200
million euro mark in the coming year
that's what I mean Fitch the CEO and
numbers man hopes he and Sonya bloemker
form commas leadership duo she's the
woman in charge of the product and I
more or less deal with the rest although
we do the marketing together marketing
when we get along really well and nobody
plays politics we look clearly to the
future and that attitude spreads to the
staff as well human chuffed
but the young brand has also made some
mistakes one example is the 2013 January
collection
Sonia Blanca used bright colors and
orange turned out to be a flop they
think that Seema I don't think orange
would have been wrong if we'd combined
it with a neutral color like the grey
skirt I have on now the mistake was
putting it next to colors like purple
any language tears have
but that seems to have been a one-off
the later collections have sold very
well and comma celebrates that fact with
music and models once a month